Noel, you up yet?
Hang on a sec,
I'm just waking up the bakers.
It's quite cramped in here.
There's only seven bakers left.
It can't be as crowded
as when there was 12 living in there?
Yeah, well, Paul and Prue
have decided to move in.
Prue's cooking breakfast.
Prue, they are not sausages.
-[Prue] Oh, sorry, Noel.
-Is Paul up yet?
Yeah. He's washing his new car.
-[water pouring]
-[Paul] Ah! Sorry.
-Sandi, can I ask you a question?
-Hmm.
How come you get to sleep in the big house
and I'm in a tiny tent?
You're the smallest person on the show.
Yeah, I've got an irony clause
in my contract.
Rahul, it's a small tent.
If you could be less animated.
Okay, I'll start the show.
This week, pastry...
[Jon] Pastry. It's got a dark side.
It's the heavy metal of all the bakings.
[Sandi] ...the bad boy of baking...
How has this happened to me?
[Sandi] ...will be fried...
-Ah.
-fired...
[Kim-Joy] I'm sort of scaring it
with a blowtorch.
[Sandi] ...and formed...
[Dan] Er, it's not cooked.
[sighs]
[Sandi] ...into the most extravagant pies
ever to grace the tent.
This is about celebration of pastry
and that is not a celebration of pastry.
[theme music playing]
Pastry. It is possessed by the Devil.
You turn your back on it
and it will eat you alive.
[Dan] Pastry's not something
I've done a whole lot of.
It is quite stressful.
It's not something I'm used to.
-Best of luck, bud, all right?
-Yeah. Thank you.
-Good luck. Have a good one. Smash it.
-Good luck. Yeah.
[Kim-Joy] Last week getting star baker,
there is always that little fear
in the back of my mind
that it's, like, upwards
and then a big crash.
[Ruby] We all started off really jovial
and having a laugh
but I think during the challenges now,
it's gonna get a bit more serious,
gonna get a bit more intense.
I do believe in myself
and I know I can go in there
and I can produce something good.
It's just whether it's good enough.
Hello, bakers, welcome to pastry week.
For your signature challenge the judges
would like you to make samosas.
Now, these delightful pastry parcels
are over a thousand years old.
Thousand years? They're gonna taste
weird, aren't they?
No, not today's ones, the...
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Er, the judges would like you to make
six sweet and six savoury samosas
with a dip to compliment.
Each set must be uniform, skilfully shaped
and beautifully presented.
Samosas in uniforms. I'm quite into that.
You have two hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake!
[laughs]
Uh-oh.
Do I make samosas? No. No.
[Ruby] I don't really like them.
I could happily not eat a samosa
ever again in my life.
If I'm being entirely honest.
[Prue] Everybody's had a savoury samosa.
I don't think many of us
have ever had a sweet one.
Whatever they want to put inside there
they can.
I like to see different colours,
different layers, different textures.
The last thing we want
is a bland, boring samosas.
For me, I'm really looking at the pastry.
How good are their pastry skills?
Traditionally, it's fried,
and when you fry a samosa,
the key thing is it's crispy,
it's thin and it's light.
This is samosa pastry with just some oil,
some plain flour,
some salt and some water.
[Sandi] Though beautiful
in its simplicity,
samosa pastry is difficult to perfect.
Just adding the water.
Ugh. I've gone over as always.
It's quite a tough dough.
It's, it's very easy
to keep on adding lashings of water
but you don't want your pastry
to be too soggy.
You want a flake. You want a bit of bite.
[Noel] Just as important is the amount
they work their dough.
[Dan] If you overwork your pastry,
the gluten gets too developed
and it springs back too strongly.
And also it's very likely to be tough.
-Morning, Jon.
-[Jon] Good morning.
-Hello, Jon.
-How is everyone?
Ah! More important, how are you, Jon,
and tell us about your samosas?
Right, my samosas are loosely based
on when I first wooed my wife
and cooked her romantic meals in my flat.
Samosas were part of the romantic meals?
No, no, no, no. The filling was.
I used to do a chicken and basil
with white wine,
so I'm doing chicken and pesto.
[Sandi] Alongside his savoury samosas,
Jon's hoping to woo the judges
with a sweet samosa filled with an orange
and vanilla crème pâtissière.
I like the flavours that you've done.
-Thank you very much.
-I like the shirt this week.
-No more compliments.
You've got a tiny bit of orange there
where you've been tasting...
[all laughing]
I've got your back, Jon,
I've got your back.
Cheers, mate.
[Ruby] I have
a traditional Indian filling.
Just thought traditional,
you can't beat it, right?
Erm, there's a reason
why everyone loves it.
Very simple flavour combinations
but they seem to work.
[Sandi] Ruby's authentic savoury samosas
will be accompanied
by an orange infused date and almond sweet
but there's something she's worried about.
'Cause I'm Indian I'm expected to--
-Oh.
-To smash the samosas.
Is there, like, extra,
extra cultural pressure.
-Yeah.
-But do you actually make samosas at home?
-No. No-one does.
-No. I don't make Danish pastries either.
[Ruby] I don't make them from scratch.
[Sandi] Does anybody in the family
make them?
No. Don't be daft.
People have got lives, Sandi.
[Sandi] While Ruby might not be
reliant on help from home,
Rahul's counting on it.
-Good morning.
-Hi.
Has your mum helped you with this one?
I did have a long conversation with mum
about samosas.
-She's in India...
-Right.
...and she made a samosa last night.
-Oh, amazing.
-Did she?
Yeah. She sent me the pictures
of the samosa.
[Noel] Rahul's mum samosas
will be accompanied
by a sweet inspired
by a traditional Indian kalakand,
packed with coconut, ricotta and cashews.
When Prue and I are gonna
be judging your samosas...
Yeah.
...it pales into insignificance against
what your mother's gonna say.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
You know that
I'm your English mummy, right?
Oh, yeah, you can be that. That's fine.
You'll never disappoint me.
You're already a winner in mummy's eyes,
-Well-- Aw, thank you.
-Rahul.
I just remembered pine nuts.
I'm gonna have to do them again.
[Briony] So my samosas are based around
my husband's favourite pie.
My husband is my
biggest baking advocate, bless him,
so also putting on a fair amount of weight
from all the baking practice.
[Sandi] Along with her pie inspired
beetroot, spinach and walnut savoury,
Briony's been expanding her
husband's waistline with a decadent sweet.
It's peanut butter cheesecake.
-Obviously.
-Obvs.
-Sorry.
-You know, you're classic samosa filling.
I feel a little foolish now. Can I try it?
Go for it.
Ooh.
Wow.
-I could just go...
-Yeah.
So I am making, er, chicken tagine.
At home, mum has the biggest tagine
and you know, in the summer,
it's something we would do often,
and she would put everything together.
So cooking for Mummy today,
for all of the time she spent
cooking for us,
running a company and having three kids.
I don't know how she did it
but, yeah. [laughs]
[Manon] Paying homage to her mum,
Manon's also making her favourite sweet,
tarte tatin.
I'm trying to get my head
round a tarte tatin in a samosa.
It can get a little bit dry.
-Erm, is that all you've got inside it?
-Yeah.
I just bake the apples
with the caramel, so, yes.
Hopefully you're gonna like it
and I've got a little stamp...
This is making quite weird noises.
Is that okay?
-Is it? I think so, yeah.
-It's speaking to me.
I'm just trying to roll out
the pastry very thin.
[Noel] To create the samosas
signature crunch,
the pastry needs to be wafer thin.
[Ruby] Quite a bit of elbow-work.
Painstaking this is.
[Noel] And while everyone
puts their back into it...
It's a pasta roller.
[Noel] ...Dan's hit upon a shortcut.
[Dan] I'm too posh to push.
My samosas are my husband's idea.
It's, like, inspired by, er,
the cheese course of Christmas dinner.
[Sandi] Dan's festive stilton,
pear and walnut savoury samosas
will be served alongside banana
and caramelised hazelnut sweets.
His fillings however,
are the least of his worries.
I'm not sure
what's going on with the dough.
It's tearing.
Bit of a schoolboy error.
I just let the machine go for too long
and my pastry got overworked
because, erm, it's...
There just looks like
there is way too much gluten in it.
So I'm just gonna
have to start another batch.
[Sandi] The bakers are halfway through.
-Are they?
-Yeah, no, you have to tell them that.
Bakers, you're halfway through.
-What is it? Wow.
-40... 47 hairs.
Such a weird place to keep a ferret.
[laughs]
[Noel] While Dan starts batch number two,
the rest of the bakers
push on with construction.
[Rahul] I form a riged pattern on it.
This is like a North Indian
samosa technique.
[Briony] So you basically fold it up.
Just so many samosas.
I'm just finishing the savoury ones.
[Ruby] This is my
traditional Indian filling.
They better like spice.
[Kim-Joy] Oh, no.
Forgot to add any of the spice.
Just so much to keep on top of,
I'm forgetting things.
[Noel] Spice week's winner
may have forgotten
to spice her savoury but Kim-Joy's hoping
her apple chai sweet
will help fend off the curse
of star baker.
You won star baker last week.
-[laughs]
-How's that feel?
Can't believe it.
[Paul] The pressure. The pressure.
I know but now there's pressure.
Okay, so let me get this straight.
This guy's gonna be with us this week
and then next week I'm gone
and he takes over?
Bakers, you only have half an hour.
Oh, Good Lord.
That machine just doesn't have
enough power to do it,
so I'm just rolling it out by hand,
which is a lot more time-consuming.
[grunting]
[Sandi] Those who have kept to schedule...
You just wish them the best of luck.
[Sandi] ...can hit the fryer.
Fry well, friends.
Ten minutes in fryer,
and fry them at 180 degrees.
[Briony] You can't put too many in at once
because it'll bring the temperature
right down.
[Noel] As if that wasn't enough
to worry about...
I'm just going to keep an eye on them,
at the same time
I'm just going to start my dip.
[Noel] ...they also have
their dipping sauces to contend with.
Oh, I've totally forgotten
about my double cream.
I'm going to have to double whip that.
-Oh, has it curdled?
-Totally curdled it. Yeah.
[Briony] Oh, my God.
That's not gonna be happening.
Oh, dear.
[gasping]
Oh, that's not all right.
Ah, damn it. Damn it. Damn it. Damn it.
That was orange syrup that over syruped.
Oh, yikes.
[Sandi] With just minutes to go,
Dan's discovered a problem
with his pastry.
Too much water.
This is a mess.
We ain't got time to worry about anything.
We gotta get these in.
Please tell me I've got
more than ten minutes left.
-Bakers, you have ten minutes.
-And I'm gonna need every minute of that
in this fryer.
I just heard something split open.
Ah, I've got one burst, two burst.
Uh! Ooh! Mm!
That's a French face you're doing.
That's definitely a French face.
The English don't make that face.
-Cannot do that with their lips. Mmm.
-Mmm.
The thing's really cold.
Maybe I'll just crank it up.
[Rahul] This is a technique
to fry the sides.
It's great.
[Ruby] All good.
This is my mum's chutney.
She is buzzing that I'm using her recipe.
[Briony] Beetroot decoration.
Pythagoras 'cause it's a triangle.
[Dan laughs] Oh, that face is a picture.
[Manon] I'm not too happy
because they have exploded.
I put too much inside.
One minute.
Oh, God, I need to make a ganache.
Very, very nervous and stressed.
Ah!
[Briony] Oh, dear. Come on.
[Jon] I'm rushing now.
[Kim-Joy] Ah!
Bakers, your time is up.
I'm done. Just about.
God, that didn't go to plan at all,
did it?
Ow. They're hot.
Stop eating them.
-What?
-Briony.
I'm not eating anything, I swear.
[imitating Briony's muffled speaking]
A whole samosa in your mouth.
[Sandi and Noel laughing]
Mine are open.
I'm scared now.
[Jon] Could be a little bit better.
Better than mine.
Yeah. That's true.
-[laughs]
-I'll take that.
[Noel] Now, the bakers' pastry will face
the judgement of Paul and Prue.
-Hello, Ruby.
-Hello.
-Beautiful.
-Thank you.
[Paul] The pastry is crispy,
thin all round.
[Ruby] Yeah. You've got potato,
peas and onions.
[exhales]
-It's quite hot.
-It's too spicy.
Sorry. I never know when to stop.
I like the fact that you haven't scrimped,
-you've just gone right, there it is.
-[Ruby] Way in-- Yeah.
What I like about it is that you've been
brave enough to say, "Right...
-Yeah.
-...I'm not going to try
and improve on the samosa
or do anything fancy,"
and you've done them perfectly.
Thank you.
[Prue] Let's try the sweet one.
Mm. Good strong orange.
[Paul] I get the almond in there.
I get the date in there.
It's a juggernaut of flavour
on both. Yeah.
-Oh!
-Yes!
-Amazing. Thank you.
-[all clapping]
-[Paul] Well done, Rube.
-Thank you so much.
Stunning. The only thing I will say is
get your mum to write down
her chutney recipe.
I will do. She'll be made up with that.
Well done, Rubes.
Thanks.
Phew.
The pastry's okay in places.
Some of them are quite soggy there.
Yeah.
Mm. The chicken pesto, it's delicious.
Yeah? Oh, thank you.
I didn't think that would work.
-[Paul] Your sweet one. Interesting.
-[Jon] The jam might need a spoon.
[laughing]
Not so much a dipping
-but bit more of a--
-It's not a dip, it's a smear.
The flavour's great.
You've got the orange,
the crème pât. Beautiful.
-[Prue] So beautiful.
-[Sandi] So beautiful.
-[Briony] Thank you.
-You can hardly bear to eat them.
I think the pastry's perfect, actually,
and the texture,
because you've got the nut in there
as well and the beetroot.
-[Prue] But the sweet one is too gluey.
-[Briony] Okay.
-Peanut butter, you always-- It always is.
-Yeah.
But great job. I mean, best looking
samosa I think I've ever seen.
Thank you.
I have never had a samosa
with a Pythagoras theorem on...
Mm.
[Paul] The pastry is beautiful and light.
Very traditional flavours.
It's almost like you're,
you're missing something.
Is it spicy enough? 'Cause I thought
it might need a bit more chilli.
That would have helped.
But I must say, the apple chai samosa
is absolutely lovely.
Okay. Thank you very much.
[laughs]
I think we know where we're going here.
[all laughing]
Bit tough, Prue?
[Sandi] How could you guess that?
-Just a bit. Just a bit.
-[all laughing]
-Oh, Dan, taste that.
-[Dan] Goodness me.
[sarcastically] Wonderfully soft.
When you lie your face goes red.
You know, you got that.
[both laughing]
It seems to be absolutely about
too much water in the pastry.
[Paul] It's gone more like a bread. See?
Mmm-hmm.
They are both like leather
but the fillings are beautiful.
Well, that's one out of two.
[Paul] I love this little pattern
you've got on the top.
They look quite authentic, don't they?
Rahul, if I tell you that
they are absolutely delicious quickly,
will you start looking happier?
[Paul] Great flavours.
What it is, is the texture.
You've got the nut, the flavours,
the spices...
-Oh, Rahul.
-...and that with the raita as well,
it's that cooling effect.
The whole thing together
'cause the pastry is beautifully crispy,
it almost melts in the mouth.
The sweet one.
The oil in the coconut is so moist.
I think it's absolutely faultless.
[Sandi laughing]
If he doesn't put his hand out
and give you a handshake,
I'm going to kill him.
That's okay. It's fine.
If you like it, that's...
Wow. Death or shake?
[exhales]
Erm, your mother would be
very proud of them.
Oh, I'm stressed a bit.
[Paul] The pastry's a little bit thick
on the top.
Yeah.
-It's split a bit on a couple there.
-Mm.
There is much more potato
than there is chicken,
so the chicken has a hard time
coming forward.
-Okay.
-[Paul] The sweet one.
I just think it's a little bit too dry.
-Okay.
-You do get the apple
but you need that caramel
and that caramel's too thick
as a dipping sauce.
This is disappointing.
It's not like Manon to miss flavour.
Anybody's game this week.
I know, mate, I know. I know.
[Manon] Not very happy with that.
Hmph. I have to do good later today.
It's good to get appreciated
by Paul Hollywood
and the way he does it by, you know,
shaking your hand.
[laughs]
I feel sorry for Paul.
My hand was probably sweaty.
I probably clammy hands
when he gave me a handshake.
That wasn't good. I should have
had a towel just to quickly...
Well, to be honest,
I wasn't expecting that at all.
Wow. I'm so happy that
I finally produced a signature
where they've gone,
"That looks really nice,"
as opposed to, "Hmm, a bit messy."
You know, like, "Yeah, finally."
[Dan] Let's hope the technical...
Top three would always be nice.
How about top?
[laughs]
[Sandi] Pastry Week isn't about
to get any easier.
The bakers have no idea
what they'll be asked to bake next.
It's time for your technical challenge
and today's gingham covered mystery recipe
has been set for you by the gorgeous Prue.
Prue, some advice?
There's a lot to do so keep calm
and keep going.
There you go.
Right, off you two pop.
What are they doing today?
I think Paul's paying Prue
to clean his cars.
-Oh.
-She's doesn't know he's got 149.
Now, the judges would love you to make
six of that French classic pastry,
puits d'amour.
Well of love.
So, rough puff pastry, choux pastry,
compote and crème pâtissière.
And you have a mere two hours
to complete this technical challenge.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
Oh, God.
Have you ever heard of one, Dan?
I haven't heard of it, mate.
I've got no idea what I'm making.
I'm a really bad French
because I'm sure a lot of people
will know about it
but I've never seen it before.
[Noel] This fancy French pastry
was invented over 250 years ago.
I've never been in a well of love.
I don't even know what a well of love is.
[Noel] It was thought to be scandalous
due to the erotic connotations
of its look and name.
Perhaps, it's a well
where you go to make love?
Didn't know I had a well of love
to be honest with you.
So, Prue, puits d'amour?
-Well of, well of love.
-Mm. Well of love.
[Paul] Why have you chosen
these beautiful pastries?
Well, mainly because
they're quite difficult.
There are five elements to this
and they have to get them all right.
First of all you have to make
a puff pastry.
It's really important to get the layers.
So you want to keep that cold.
Then they have to pipe a perfect ring
of choux pastry
but in the meantime they make
the compote and the crème pât,
which they blowtorch to a caramel.
[Paul chuckles] Right,
I've gotta try one of these.
I hate to think we've got to eat
seven of these.
Hate?
The trouble
is I'll eat them all. [chuckles]
Bring it on.
Haven't had the best start of the day,
so, I need to do well. Yeah.
They're really,
really detailed instructions.
"Make the rough puff
by grating the frozen butter
into the flour and salt."
Don't overwork it.
You don't want to melt the butter.
I think I have melted the butter already.
Oh, my God, this is so bad of me.
I need to chill it. Oh, nightmare.
There's mine.
This is a French challenge,
how come you've never heard of it?
I know. I've spent too long in England.
[Noel] Do you think
you'll be here forever?
[Manon] If I find
an English husband, yeah.
Are you looking for an English husband?
I tried.
You've tried? What? No takers?
Wow. I think
you're gonna get some letters.
I love working with puff pastry.
Love all the rolling and folding.
The folding is a technique that you'd do
to get the layers.
Tac-tac-tac.
So I'm doing a book fold, erm,
which creates four layers.
[Sandi] Hey, Mr Handshake.
Oh, my God.
Why do you have to start with that?
Noel did the same thing.
Why are you never pleased?
What happened with Paul,
did you get a handshake?
No. No. They were really
complimentary though.
Paul said they were the best samosas
he'd ever seen.
-Paul who?
-Paul Hollywood.
Oh, yeah. I like that guy.
Yeah, he's all right.
-Can he bake?
-Been around a while-- I think he can.
Prue's the one you want to watch out for.
Yeah, she's trouble.
It just says, "Make the compote,"
and then the crème pât.
Oh, okay.
[Kim-Joy] So the compote's okay.
I think I'm fairly confident
of the crème pât.
[Dan] This is crème pât ingredients.
So when you have finished
separating your eggs,
you've got these lovely egg whites,
never let them go
'cause there's good protein in there.
Mm. Reminds me of Rocky.
[Ruby] Is that looking as good?
Looking as everyone else's?
This eggs and milk and a bit of butter.
[Dan] You heat it until it burps.
You gonna burp?
No, not yet.
[Dan] Do you think that's thick enough?
[Noel] I think that's thick enough
but I have no idea what it is,
so good luck.
[Noel] What have you drawn?
Yeah, so it's a bun, and he's angry
and it's really hot.
Toad in the Hole. Brilliant.
Bakers, you have one hour left. One hour.
"Make the choux." Okay.
Flour, butter, sugar, eggs.
Mix. Mix. Mix. Mix.
Ugh.
You want it to come clean off the sides.
Cor, I hate this bit.
[exhales]
[Ruby] Has yours come together?
[Dan] I'm slightly concerned
about my choux.
I'm just returning it to the heat
and trying to thicken it up
a little bit more
'cause it does not look right.
Right, "Roll out the pastry and cut out
six ten centimetre rounds."
"Using the small piping nozzle,
pipe the choux in a circle,
half a centimetre in from the edge
of each pastry disc."
Doesn't make any sense,
so stopped reading.
So I'm doing a circle. I think.
I don't fully know, like,
whether to space it out or not?
I guess if they haven't said...
It's not that I don't wanna to help you,
it's that I have no idea.
This is my interpretation.
I really had no idea what to do.
[gasps] Fudge.
In a circle. A centimetre. So not circles.
In a circle. Oh, man. Read, Rubes, read.
Not good.
Bakers, you've got half an hour left.
Nibbled sugar for sprinkling?
[Manon] I like it like this.
Look at ten.
-"Bake."
-That's it. Nothing else. Cheers, mate.
-[laughs]
[Jon] Right. Get them in.
Heat up and...
Me being me, I'm really scared.
I'm gonna check after 15
and see what happens.
[whispering] 18.
[Briony] Oh, no.
So I forgot the nibbed sugar
but I'm not gonna open the oven
because it'll let the steam out
and that will stop the choux from rising.
So that's a big no-no.
Yeah.
[Jon] You all right?
Yeah, just forgot to put
the bloody sugar on.
Right, shall we try that again?
Right, okay.
They're puffing up a little bit, yeah.
[Sandi] Beautiful.
I quite like that
they were thought to be naughty.
-I think that fun, don't you?
-Yes. Yeah.
[Ruby] Mine are overflowing.
Just got too much love to give, guys.
Don't know when to take it out.
Just have to take the risk.
Uh-oh. You can't see that.
Oh, man.
I'm too, like, embarrassed
to take mine out.
Oh, man.
[Dan] The choux hasn't
risen properly. Terrible.
[sighs]
I'm pleased with them, yeah.
They're looking okay.
Just adding the nibbed sugar
that I forgot to put on.
Briony's look really good.
How has this happened to me?
[sighs]
Bakers, you have five minutes.
Just five minutes.
"To assemble, spoon the strawberry compote
into the pastry shells."
Oh, I can't even look at them.
"Add the crème pâtissière over the top."
Hmm. That looks terrible.
[Briony] "Sprinkle the demerara sugar
on top of the crème pât.
Using the blowtorch, brûlée the sugar."
I bought a blowtorch recently
but I was really freaked out by it.
Ugh.
One minute left, bakers.
I don't even know how to do it.
[Briony] Ooh, God.
I'm trying not to burn the choux.
That is horrific.
Bakers, that is the end
of your technical challenge.
It's bad. It's bad.
I'm quite pleased.
I'm not.
Please place your wells of love
behind your photos on the table.
[Sandi] Paul and Prue are expecting
six perfect puits d'amour.
Discs of flaky puff pastry,
crowned with rings of choux pastry
and topped with bruled crème pâtissière.
Okay, we'll start with number one.
Quite dark, don't you think?
I think that's probably
not enough compote.
And not enough crème pât.
It tastes fine. Aeration in the choux.
-Hmm.
-Crispy base. It's just a little bit dark.
Okay, moving on.
This is actually a bit more
-like the one we're looking for.
-That's a classic.
[Paul] It's a nice,
strong colour underneath.
Very good compote.
[Paul] The aeration you've got
in the choux is fantastic.
[Prue] It is very good.
[Paul] Okay. Erm,
quite flat.
It is painfully thin that,
erm, puff pastry.
-Flavour's there though.
-[Prue] Oh, it's good.
[Paul] Nice tartness.
It looks, like, erm...
-Well, it's been cremated, isn't it?
-It is a bit... Yeah, too brown.
I think the choux pastry was a little bit
too soft when it was piped out.
I can taste a little bit of burnt in that.
Okay, nice interpretation.
[Prue] Very original look.
[Paul] Bit dark again but not bad.
The crème pât's quite firm
but it is delicious.
[Paul] Moving on.
Crème pât. We seem to have a split.
It's very flat, that choux, as well.
That choux pastry was not cooked enough.
Yeah, there's no well.
There's no sides to it.
No. I'm gonna eat some anyway.
Component parts are okay.
It's just that pastry, it's a real shame.
Okay, last one.
These are quite neat.
Quite a nice little colour.
Nice bit of piping work as well.
[Prue] That is a beautiful shape.
[Paul] Yeah.
Mm. Tastes delicious.
[Noel] But whose "puits d'amour"
is filled to the brim with love?
In the hall of shame,
we have this one, number seven.
It tastes absolutely delicious
but it is the worse one here.
In sixth place is this one. Whose is this?
Flat as a pancake. What happened?
Erm, I am stupid.
I opened the oven because I forgot
to put the sugar on and, yeah...
And it collapsed.
[Noel] Kim-Joy is fifth,
Manon is fourth
and Rahul is third.
In second spot,
is this one.
Jon. All the elements were fantastic.
Well done.
So, in top place...
[all] Yeah. Yeah.
[Prue] Briony, they were elegant,
they were uniform
and they were utterly delicious.
Oh, thank you so much. Thank you.
Oh!
Yay. I still can't believe that.
Genuinely never thought I'd come first
in a technical. This is awesome.
I can make choux.
I assure you. I ass-choux you.
Middle. I take middle today.
The day has gone slightly better
and tomorrow...
I have to do well tomorrow.
I just feel embarrassed
because it was just such a terrible day
and it looks like I can't bake.
I'm going to go and have a drink.
[chuckles]
[buzzing]
[Sandi] One challenge remains.
One last chance for the bakers
to earn their place in the tent.
I think one of the most
pleasing things this week
is the soaring success of Briony.
I know. I know,
in the first couple of weeks
I thought she's not gonna last.
[Paul] She's in line,
possibly for star baker
and I think Rahul is obviously
up there as well.
-Do you wanna a secret bet?
-Yeah.
I'll have Rahul, you have Briony.
[Sandi] Let's have a look at the, erm,
people who are in some difficulty.
[Prue] Dan. It was surprising.
I mean, he has done so well up till now.
[Paul] Manon is in trouble.
She did struggle with the samosas.
Ruby on the other hand did really badly
in the technical.
So I have to put Ruby in there,
even though she got the handshake
in the samosa.
[Sandi] Nerves play a part, don't they?
We're down to seven.
It is really a wide open field now.
Yeah.
Hello, bakers, welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your Showstopper.
Today Paul and Prue would like you to make
a shaped banquet pie,
which is basically a pie
in the shape of a banquet.
Yeah, not completely, really.
Er, the judges are looking
for a beautifully decorated
and impressively shaped sharing pie,
which will be right at home
as centre piece at a Tudor banquet.
[Noel] You can use any filling,
any pastry,
but it must be shaped with your own hands.
You've got three and a half hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake!
I've got to nail it. It'll be fine.
She says now.
Oh, God.
I have to get it right.
There's no two ways about it.
I liked it when I kept getting handshakes.
Let's go back to that, I think.
[Paul] What we're looking for, really,
is a beautifully designed
ornate pie,
fit enough to go on a king's table.
[Prue] One of the chief problems
with those pies,
is the juice is likely to leak out.
We don't want anything that's too dry.
We don't want anything that's too soggy.
They have to get that perfect balance.
[Paul] They can't use a mould
but they can use their hands
to manipulate and shape whatever pastry
they're gonna use.
This is the bakers chance, really,
to show us their...
Little bit of artistic flair.
-[Prue] Briony.
-[Paul] Good morning, Briony.
[Briony] Hi. Hi. Hi.
Right, would you like to tell us
all about your banquet pie?
It's based around Alice in Wonderland,
hence the dress.
So it's going to be the Mad Hatter's hat.
The steam hole at the top is going to have
Alice's legs
and her skirt coming out as she goes down
-the rabbit hole.
-The rabbit hole.
[Prue] This is the entire story
-of Alice in Wonderland...
-Yeah, I'm trying...
-...in one hat.
-[Briony] I know. Yeah.
[Sandi] Briony won't just be keeping
Alice's adventures under her hat,
her pie will be crammed
with rich layers of mushroom,
sweet potato and venison.
You're putting Bambi
in an Alice in Wonderland hat.
I'm just feeling slightly stressed now.
How are you soaking up the liquid?
I'm actually making some savoury pancakes
to soak up, erm...
It's just the thing is, like,
with meat and game it's just so juicy.
Briony, I'm really worried about time.
Come on, Paul, let's leave the girl.
-Good luck.
-Thank you.
You're late, you're late,
for a very important date.
Oh, God.
The hurrier I go, the behinder I get.
[Sandi] Time is a gift. Every minute.
Every second.
And most of the bakers are sticking
with a traditional pie pastry
that's quick to produce...
My pastry is very simple.
It's hot water crust.
I just thought that making sure
it's given enough time in the oven
is gonna be really key.
[Sandi] But Dan, Jon and Kim-Joy
are going off-piste.
We love puff pastry.
This is the heavy metal of all the bakes.
Ozzy and Slipknot is puff pastry.
[Sandi] Full puff pastry is made
with layers of butter
that need time to chill.
Because I wanna keep my pastry nice
and cold, it's taking me a bit longer.
[Noel] They're hoping the wait
will be worth it
as the flakes they achieve
should enhance their designs.
So, my pie's gonna be shaped like a fish.
[Noel] For Dan, it will create
the illusion of fish scales.
His pie will feature layers of rice,
boiled egg and lightly smoked salmon.
You're shaping the fish...
detailing with the puff pastry itself?
Yes.
So it's gonna have scales
and a tail and...
Yeah, I mean, I had this interesting idea
but I don't know if it's a good idea.
Erm, you know, salmon is sort of black
and silver and then, like, lighter.
I've got some sprays and stuff
but I'm not sure.
-So yeah...
-He's not keen.
Glitter is not the way to go.
I don't know.
You're more of a purist, aren't you?
[Prue] Yes, yes, but silvery fish?
I mean, I think that you should do
what you think is right.
-We don't matter.
-[scoffs] Clearly.
[both laugh]
I am making a mermaid pie
and it's called
Silke the Vegetarian Mermaid.
[Sandi] Like Dan, Kim-Joy's
relying on puff pastry
to enhance Silke's scales
and she's not afraid to use glitter.
Her pie will be filled
with her favourite veggie flavours,
beetroot, butternut squash,
feta and caramelised onion.
-I played a merman once called Old Greg.
-Oh, wow. Oh.
-Yeah, he was a sea transsexual.
-Oh!
Quite a demanding role for me.
Morning, Jon.
-Good morning, Paul.
-Hi, lovely.
Can you tell us about your banquet pie
then? What are you doing?
Is it something Welsh? Please tell me.
I'm doing a Welsh dragon pie.
-Hey.
-With lamb?
No, with dragon.
[all chuckling]
[Noel] Jon couldn't find any dragon
but his pie should still have
fire in its belly
with a chilli infused mix of mince beef,
leeks and carrots
and he's not shying away
from decorating his puff pastry scales.
It's gonna be green.
-It's gonna be green?
-Yeah.
[all laughing]
It's gonna be green puff pastry.
What is that device called?
-Er, this is my meat mincer thingy.
-It's like a toilet brush.
[Jon] Yeah, but it does work.
It's really good.
It's like my mini whisks and my chopper
and things like that.
-I don't wanna hear about that.
-[laughing]
All right then, Jon, should be finished
in about, ooh, an hour?
Yeah, yeah, about that. With puff pastry
it doesn't take long, does it?
I'm just sort of at a bit of a loose end,
'cause, I mean,
I'm still waiting for my pastry.
[Sandi] While those with puff pastry
wait for it to chill...
The rest of the bakers push on
with construction.
So, this is a rye pancake to line
the bottom of the pastry case,
because it helps with the moisture.
[Ruby] I added in rice.
I'm hoping that will take a lot
of the stress out of the soggy bottom.
[Rahul] The shape is like a butterfly
and basically a curry filling.
I think about the flavours
that I had as a child
and try to kind of reciprocate it
in my own way.
[Sandi] Rahul's calling on a secret
family recipe to spice his lamb curry.
He'll be embellishing his pie
with rich decorative colours
and intricate shaping.
What are you making now, a worm?
No, I'm making the tentacles.
[Noel] Butterflies have tentacles?
Butterflies have tentacles.
They are antennae.
No tentacle is the one that
they suck the nectar from.
That's their tongue, that's their tongue.
Oh, never mind.
You say tentacle, I say antennae.
Let's call the whole thing off.
So, the shape of my pie is a crown
inspired by the Kohinoor crown
which India surrendered to England
during the British Raj.
Erm, and the jewels in there
are absolutely amazing. It's fantastic.
[Noel] Beneath the jewels of Ruby's crown
will be a layer of chicken curry
sat atop a rice base.
[Noel] You all right?
Rahul's doing curry as well.
Well, 'course he bloody is, he can't ever
let me have my two minutes, can he?
-[laughing]
-Sick of that guy.
[Noel] Do you want me to taste yours
and see which is better?
[Ruby] Let me just--
Taste mine. Yeah, please.
I know what you're gonna do,
I don't even want to look at your face.
-Delicious.
-Oh, that wasn't what I was expecting.
-It's got a little kick.
-It has.
-Oh!
-Oh, sweet Lord. That's good.
[Jon] I'm gonna go for it there.
[Sandi] An hour into the challenge,
Jon and Kim-Joy can wait no more.
If I was making this at home
I'd make it over a longer time.
Harden up the butter a little bit more
because then you get
better layers from it.
This is not good. But, yeah,
just got to work as fast as possible.
[Noel] Dan's, however,
is nowhere to be seen.
You all right, Dan? Are you done?
Er, no, not yet. I'm waiting on...
[Noel] In an effort
to salvage pastry week,
he's gambling on the perfect puff.
You know, obviously,
I want to do well today.
So, I thought if I made my pastry perfect
it will be really impressive.
But, er, it's a bit terrifying
because...just making sure
I've got enough time to do it all.
[Sandi] Another baker fighting
for survival is Manon.
-Morning.
-Hey, Manon.
Tell us all about your banquet pie.
What are you doing?
So, I'm making poppy.
-Poppy?
-Yeah.
-Which is an octopus.
Oh, it's an octopus.
And so, she's eating some whiting fish
with scallops and some salmon paste.
[Sandi] Manon's banking on her octopus
to keep her afloat for another week.
Hope you like it.
Just make sure it comes out
how you want it to come out
and do the best that you can.
[Noel] Bakers, you're halfway through.
So, if you've got pastry that you need
cooking, put it in the oven.
Baking, cooking whatever.
What is this show?
Who am I? Is this a dream?
I love you, Jon.
[chuckles]
[Jon] I'm rushing now.
[Kim-Joy] Time is not good.
Oh, God, I'm not ready.
[Noel] Those with
fully constructed pies...
That's it, I'm going in.
Let's go. You're going in.
[Noel] ...can start the bake.
Poppy's going inside
for an hour and 15 minutes.
I forgot to put the steam hole in.
Steam hole is very important
just to help release any moisture...
It can all come out from that hole.
[Noel] Who's your favourite baker in here?
Whisper it.
-No, I can't. I'm not going to say that.
-Really.
Jon.
I'm not going to say any names.
What about Ruby and Manon?
I love them as sisters. Can't choose
any favourites, that's the thing...
-Who's your favourite presenter?
-[Ruby] I look like you.
Me? Come on, Rahul,
I thought it was Sandi.
[Sandi] Is it gonna be ready?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
[Sandi] But will those with puff pastry
be ready?
I'm a little bit against it with time,
so I need to get this in the oven.
[Kim-Joy] Puff pastry takes like
40-45 minutes to bake.
[Sandi] While Kim-Joy and Jon catch up...
[humming]
Hopefully, that's a good amount of time.
I don't think I could handle
messing up three in a row.
[Sandi] Dan's lost track of time.
How long have we got left?
Bakers, you have 45 minutes left.
Well then, yes, I mean, obviously,
I need to get it in immediately.
Erm, so I need one piece for the back.
Oh, God, how am I gonna do this?
This is so not how I wanted this
to go down.
[Rahul] Oh, my God,
my pie is already leaking.
Erm, it's going to be so under-baked.
[Ruby] I can see Dan's not in the oven.
I want to ask him if he wants help
but I know,
also, it will probably stress him out.
[Jon] Is it all right, Dan?
Don't let him hear this
but if Dan went, I would miss him.
[Dan] Everything inside it is cooked
so I literally just need the pastry
to brown.
And how long does that take?
Half an hour?
Okay. We've got half an hour.
[Dan] Oh, don't tear.
I'm gonna go.
Come on. Let's get it in the oven.
[exhales]
[Ruby] Decoration done.
Did somebody say croquet?
They look so good.
Oh, I'm scared now.
Maybe Poppy's too simple?
We'll see.
-Well done, Briony.
-[Briony] Thank you.
[Jon] Fancy a flying saucer?
[Noel] Let's go back to the '70s.
They've still got the taste of polystyrene
but then wait for it...
-Wait for it. It's coming.
-Here comes the fizz.
Hmm...
-Hmm.
-Getting the fizz.
I'm on my space hopper.
I've got flares on.
-That's the way.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
Just 15 minutes.
Oh, Good Lord.
-Poppy has exploded.
-What exploded?
-Poppy.
-Poppy?
Poppy's the octopus.
Poppy, don't explode.
-Stop exploding.
-No, I know.
[Manon] The hole for the steam
is a tiny bit smaller.
Little bottles of port, I would never
bribe the judges with alcohol.
Rahul? I just saw an octopus
with antennae.
[Dan] Ugh, it's not cooked.
Shall I just turn it up more?
I don't know what to do.
[Ruby] This is just my decorative stand.
I'll have to wait
until it comes out of the oven.
Sack it, I'm doing it.
[Kim-Joy] No.
Butter leakage.
Damn it. Mine's leaking tons.
Didn't have time to chill all my butter.
[Manon] So, there's some juice
that's so annoying.
Oh, my God, that looks so a mess.
[Dan sighs]
He's a bit of a baby, isn't he?
I know size doesn't matter
but it's a banquet.
You're talking to the wrong person
about size.
I literally can't turn the oven up
any hotter.
[Manon] Ah!
It is stuck on the bottom.
I don't really understand.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
One minute remaining.
If your pie is still in the oven
it will need to come out now.
Wow, great.
I think I'm just gonna spray it
in some colour so it's more inventive.
Maybe Alice's feet could do
with a little touch-up.
Ah!
[Dan] This is battling
to be here next week.
[Jon] Damn it, damn it, damn it.
Ah!
[Rahul] Oh, my God.
Right, my lovelies, time is up.
[Ruby] That looks so good.
[Dan] Hopefully that cooked through.
-Off you pop.
-Off you pop, kids.
Don't worry, darling.
I still have some baking paper underneath.
It's so bad.
-There he is.
-Skipping out.
A pie skipper.
And then there was just one.
A man alone with his thoughts
in a canvas tent
in an empire of pastry.
[Sandi] The bakers' banquet pies
now face the judgement of Paul and Prue.
Kim-Joy, please bring up
your shaped banquet pie.
"Silke The Vegetarian Mermaid."
-[all laugh]
-[Prue] That is so Kim-Joy.
It looks great
and what a great looking puff pastry,
you can see by the flakes in that.
But there's quite a big spot of dough
there where it's extra thick,
-which is a little bit worrying.
-[Kim-Joy] Yeah.
[Paul] The caramelised onion
works really well.
The beetroot works and everything works
but it's just that pastry's too soggy.
It's a pity
because it's so beautifully made
and it its top marks for decoration.
The colour's good, decorations good.
It's quite effective.
[Prue] The plaiting of that,
it's astonishing.
[Paul] It's held together lovely.
Hmm, Ruby, that is really good
hot water crust pastry.
-Thank you.
-It's tasty, it's crisp.
The rice has really done its job
of soaking in all the juices
down to the bottom.
That with the curry together
is absolutely delicious.
It's a great pie.
-Amazing, thank you.
-Thank you.
[Prue] The insect's just exquisite.
I love the colours. Beautiful.
But as soon as you get inside
it starts to get a little bit wet.
I put only two little steam holes,
I should have put more.
I love that.
[Paul] The lamb is beautifully cooked,
and the flavours, the spices
are perfectly blended.
Jon, I think the dragon lost the fight?
Where's his wings?
-Not all dragons have wings.
-Oh, right.
Wh-- Oh, let's get
into the reality of this.
[all laughing]
It's a monster sausage roll, isn't it?
It tastes delicious.
But it's really wet.
This is full butter puff pastry.
It's all about the chilling process
to get a bit of flake butteriness
and you never thought that through.
Time constraints with everything else
was my problem.
Looks more like a monkfish
than it does a salmon, doesn't it?
Looks great though.
I know we had this conversation before
but my reaction is just that
it doesn't look appetising.
I don't want to eat it
partly because it's so good.
It looks like a great raw fish
sitting there.
Feel like it needs cooking.
Yeah.
Does it?
Quite possibly.
[chuckling]
[Paul] It's raw all the way around.
It could have been a bit of dough,
you know what I mean, anything.
The fish is a lovely flavour,
coriander pancakes delicious too.
But this is about pastry,
it's about a celebration of pastry.
[Dan] Yeah, I know.
-And that is not a celebration of pastry.
-No, it isn't.
It's clever. The idea's sound enough
and I do like the look of it.
-Thank you very much, Dan.
-Thank you.
[Paul] You wouldn't know
unless you said that's an octopus.
If you'd opened it up a bit
and really elaborated on the fact
that they are tentacles,
it would have looked more effective.
There is a bit of baking paper underneath.
It's on baking paper?
-'Cause it got stuck?
-Yes.
[Paul] I'm taking the paper with me.
-See that underneath Prue?
-[Prue] Hm-mm.
It needed longer.
Hmm, a bit too much salt.
-It's very salty, isn't it?
-Hmm.
[Prue] It's too salty,
it's a little bit dry.
The pastry needed more baking
and the fish needed less cooking.
-You are a dark horse, aren't you?
-[laughs]
-It's absolutely wonderful.
-Thank you.
[Paul] The little intricate pieces of work
looks very clever.
And that's playable croquet
with the little flamingos.
[Prue] Oh, look there's the hedgehog.
[Briony] There's the hedgehog ball
and he'll go through the little--
Okay, here we come.
[Briony cheers and laughs]
You missed.
Okay, I think the baking of it
is very good.
-Thank you.
-I hold reservation,
because you've got game in there as well
and it's notorious for flooding out
when you cut it.
Yes, I know,
I am a bit nervous about that.
[Paul] Well done.
[Prue] Look at that.
-[Paul] Well done.
-[exhales and laughs]
[Prue] Oh, my God.
-Is this sweet potato?
-[Briony] Yes.
Well, I would have had much more of it.
-I... Yeah.
-That much venison is quite an ask.
-Glass of port? Port?
-Yes, please.
That's my girl.
This is pure Prue. Port, venison, croquet.
[all laughing]
I am happy.
And very slightly Mad Hatter-y.
-Yeah.
-[Briony] Thank you.
-Good stuff, well done.
-Oh, thank you. Thank you very much.
[all clapping]
[Briony] Really useful feedback
and I agree with them.
It would be amazing to get star baker,
of course, it would.
We'll wait and see, you never know.
Obviously, I could have done better.
It wasn't my days this week.
[voice breaking] If I get to next week
I'll be so happy.
I don't know if I can speak. [sniffles]
[Sandi] The one that seemed to me
to stop the show,
Briony's one, I just thought
it looked fantastic.
Oh, it was fantastic.
The whole of Alice in Wonderland
from page one to page 88 was there.
And a pie in the shape of a hat's
funny, right?
It is and I think she's in line
for star baker.
And I'd have to say, Rahul,
even though he disappointed slightly
with the pie...
The flavours were great.
Talking about fillings, you really liked
Ruby's filling, didn't you?
Oh, Ruby did get
her flavour combinations right
and the baking was very, very good.
Has she saved herself
enough to be star baker
or not quite that much?
I wouldn't-- You see, I wouldn't discount
her from star baker.
[Sandi] So where are we with Manon?
Too much sea salt in the octopus?
Yes, that was the one filling
that was badly flavoured
and it was overcooked.
She is certainly in the danger zone.
Really, really disappointing.
Let's have a look at the, er, salmon,
'cause I mean it does look sort of broad.
That's part of the fun,
it's almost like an illusion cake,
you know, and he's made like a real fish.
But the pastry was terrible.
I felt disappointed
because he's been so good
and so up there for weeks.
[Sandi] He has been star baker.
He just occasionally does things
where you think, "Wow."
-He's got a gift.
-He could get to the final.
Right, bakers,
end of a pastry filled week.
Now, one person
has really impressed throughout.
It has been a stellar performance
and I am delighted to tell you
that this week's star baker is Briony.
[all applauding]
Well done, babe.
-Thank you.
-Excellent.
Unfortunately, that leaves me
with the horrible job
of sending someone home...
And the person who's leaving us this week
is...
Dan.
Come on, mate.
Never mind.
-You had a really good run.
-[Kim-Joy] You're my Ms Cracker.
You had a good run, mate.
-You had a great run.
-Ah. Thank you.
[indistinct chatter]
It was a disastrous week though,
wasn't it?
Really sorry for you.
I think you're an incredible baker.
I am.
Yeah, well, that was expected, wasn't it?
It didn't take Nostradamus
to see that coming.
Oh, I shall miss you, Kim-Joy.
-Well, we will catch up.
-We will.
[Dan] I've had some good moments.
You know as a stay-at-home parent,
sometimes you don't get to feel
very sort of special or important,
so it's been quite nice to...
It's been quite nice to do
something for me.
[Prue] Oh, Dan.
Yeah, it was a bit of a mess though,
wasn't it?
[Prue] It was a bit, but it's such a pity
because you're such a good baker.
I think, sometimes,
pastry can be quite tricky
and I think pastry
was Dan's Achilles heel.
Sorry to see you go, mate.
I really am, genuinely, mate.
-Do better next week, please, Manon.
-Yeah, I will.
Relieved. Paul told me, er,
you better do better next week.
No pressure.
Thank you so much, Paul.
I'm thrilled, thank you.
I absolutely love Briony
and it's such a pleasure
to see her just burst out
and start blooming.
Star baker.
[Briony's husband whoops]
[indistinct chattering]
Thanks, hello, darling.
[Briony's mother] Say,"Well done."
[Briony's husband]
Say, "Well done, Mummy."
-[Briony's mother] No, she's not coming.
-No, she's not gonna say it, no.
[Briony's husband]
Oh, well, it's amazing.